AMD is launching two mid-range gpus
today and in this video I'm going to
talk about the RX 7800 XD that I have
right here and then I will cover the
7700 XD in my next video so the RX 7800
XD is a $500 or 560 graphics card that
is pretty much positioned just above
nvidia's RTX 4060 TI and just under the
RTX
4070 and it costs roughly the same as
the 3-year-old 6800 XT will cost you
today now we spent the last couple of
days testing and retesting a bunch of
gpus so let's see the results let's see
how these cards compare to each other in
over 30 games on three different
resolutions and let's see if this brand
new RX 7800 XT is worth getting or not
let's begin looking at the specs the RX
7800 XD is in a bit of a strange spot it
is called the 7800 XT but in their own
communication AMD Compares it to the
6800 non XD and if we look at a core
count it also matches the 6800 non XD so
it feels more like a non XT successor
even though it is called XD the same
goes for the price the 7800 XT launches
at $500 which is actually lower than the
launch price of both the 6800 and 6800
XT but keep in mind uh those cards
launched mid pandemic when the demand
was pretty high and the prices were
extremely high now you can get a new
6800 XD for about $500 or
€550 nowadays uh making it a perfect
comparison for this video the 7000
series does have some improvements uh it
uses a better process which typically
leads to better efficiency the clock
speeds are up uh memory performance is
up and it comes with some nice extra
features like AI accelerators and
support for av1 encoding now compared to
its main Nvidia counter part the 7800 XD
has more memory so the RTX 4070 has 12
GB while the 7800 XD comes with 16 GB of
memory the card I'm testing with is the
AMD reference model uh which actually
looks and feels like a really solid card
it is not too large so it should fit
most cases but it is slightly thicker
than two slots so if you plan to make a
build in a smaller ITX case uh do make
sure it will fit before buying it amdp
typically adds red details to their
cards but they kept it very minimal this
time around so it should match really
well with the majority of motherboards
and majority of cases out there it uses
two regular 8 Pin power connectors so
you don't need to worry about adapters
or getting new cables and so on and
unlike Nvidia who is still using display
port 1.4 AMD does include three display
port 2.1 connections next to a single
HDMI 2.1 connection which which which is
all very nice but you can also argue if
this is actually useful on a c that is
aimed at 1440p gaming but let's get to
the actual performance right away so for
this video I will be comparing the $500
7800 XT to the $500 6800 XD uh the
Nvidia RTX 4060 TI which is about $100
cheaper and the RTX 4070 which is about
$100 more in the US or about €70 more
here in the Netherlands the RX 77 100 XD
will be slightly cheaper however I
didn't get it early from AMD and I
cannot include it in this video but
gigabyte was kind enough to send one
over so we are testing it right now and
I will talk about it in my next video
along with their 7800 XT model as well
now let's start with Boulders Gate 3
which is one of the best games I've ever
played I think now this data was
collected with the latest patch 2
applied and on 1080p ultra settings the
7800 XT roughly matches the 6800 XT
while the 4070 is just barely ahead the
460 TI is trailing behind but only when
looking at 1% lows on 1440p resolution
the average FPS remains great on the AMD
cards but the 1% lows do drop more
significantly than with the RTX 4070
even if they still do look better than
with the RTX 4060 TI now Starfield is an
AMD feature title and you can really see
that the results the RX 7800 XT is far
ahead of the other three cards showing
really good numbers on both resolutions
and this is a brand new game that really
struggled to hit 60 FPS on majority of
PCS you can see the 4060 TI struggled to
hit 60 FPS on 1080P and the RTX 470
Falls below 60 FPS on
1440p as well now keep in mind I am
testing this in a city environment so
performance is worse here than in other
parts of the game and since Starfield is
only officially launching today it is
very likely that it will see some
performance patches in the next few
weeks and that these numbers might end
up being completely different which is
why I probably won't include Starfield
in the overall results today uh Remnant
2 is another new title that came out a
few weeks ago and here the 7800 XT comes
out strong yet again beating both the
6800 XT and the 4070 by a good margin on
both resolutions in Microsoft flight
simulator the new card is a small
upgrade over the older one with a small
but almost insignificant lead over the
4070 at 1440p with a 4060 TI trailing
behind at well under 60 FPS on 1080p CPU
limits come into play and the three
better gpus ended up performing
similarly in Spider-Man remastered the
7800 XD shows a small improvement over
the 6800 XT yet again but here the 4070
is ahead by a significant margin on both
1080P and 1440p with a 4060 TI not far
behind the AMD cards God of War is a
game that really seems to do well with
AMD the 6800 XT was already ahead of the
4070 and the 7800 XT extends that lead
by a good margin even if all cards
manage to play this game well on both
1080P and 1440p Assassin's Creed
Valhalla is an AMD sponsored title and
it ends up looking similar to God of War
the 7800 XT is ahead of the 6800 XT and
the 4070 on 1080P and 40 40p with the
4060 TI again trailing by quite a bit
Dying Light 2 on the other hand is an
Nvidia sponsored title uh even though
that isn't that obvious from these
results interestingly enough the new
7800 XD actually ended up dropping a bit
behind the 6800 XD and with that the RTX
470 as well cyberpunk 2077 is another
Nvidia sponsored title and generally we
saw Nvidia gpus outperform their AMD
counterparts in each class however the
RX 7800 XT shows improvement over the
6800 XT pretty nicely which puts it
ahead of the RTX 4070 although do keep
in mind that this is on high settings
without rate racing where Nvidia would
typically do better Doom Eternal is a
super easy game to run and as always
pretty much every recent GPU will run
this very smoothly on any resolution
still it is a very good test uh because
it scales well with GPU performance I
here the 7800 XT dropped below the 6800
XD especially on 1080P and the RTX 47t
is ahead in Formula 1 2022 on ultra high
settings which include rate tracing uh
so it generally favors Nvidia cards the
RX 7800 XD is again a small upgrade over
the 6800 XD the 470 is a bit ahead here
but not by a huge amount as always to
keep it a bit shorter I'm not going to
talk about every individual game because
um most titles do follow the same trend
of what you can expect from this card uh
so let's look at some summaries instead
on 1080p the 7800 XT gets you 120 FPS or
more in almost every title of 33 games
we tested for this video now there are a
couple of exceptions like Starfield and
Microsoft flight simulator that sit a
little bit below that but those are
running into CPU limitations and I still
think they are perfectly playable on
1440p which is probably the more
reasonable resolution for a $500 GPU you
would generally get a 100 FPS plus
experience as well with a couple of
exceptions in the 70 to 90 FPS range now
all those titles do include FSR if you
want a bit more FPS so it will
definitely still be a capable 1440p card
in the years to come now the 7800 XT is
not really marketed as a 4K card but I
still think it's worth testing on this
resolution when you have a card in this
price range uh and it doesn't look that
bad overall so the majority of games do
run comfortably at 60 FPS or more but
the 7800 XT does start to show some
weaker results here uh with some games
down into 40s or even 30s but generally
speaking uh you can get those above 60
FPS using FSR yet again uh some games
like Nvidia sponsored control uh do not
have that option but if you're okay with
dropping rare titles like that to medium
settings instead uh you will still get
an okay 4K resolution experience overall
when we compare those numbers to the
3-year-old RX 6800 XT they actually end
up being very similar on 1080p the 7800
XT is a bit faster in in most games uh
sometimes with 10% or more but there are
games where it's a bit slower as well on
average the 7800 XD ended up only 3%
ahead of the 6800 XD on 1440p where we
have fewer CPU bottlenecks the 7800 XT
is faster in most games but again by a
very small margin and overall there is
only 3% between the two cards in 7800
xd's favor on 4K resolution we get a
very similar picture as before with the
7800 XT being about 4% faster than the
6800 XT so when we look at the raw
performance it is very clear that 7800
XT is not really an upgrade over the
last gen 6800 XD it does look a lot
better when you compare it to the RTX
4060 TI the 8 GB version uh even on
1080p the 7800 XT is faster by almost
30% on average and on 1440p that Gap
grows to more than 40% which is a huge
difference in overall experience the 8
GB 460 TI is significantly cheaper but
when you're already spending $400 or
more on a
46ti I would personally be very tempted
to just spend another 100 or so uh for
these much much better numbers but when
we compare it to the RTX 4070 which thus
cost about $100 or €70 more than the
7800 XT
the results are once again very close on
1080p both cards have some clear wins
but overall there is a very slight 2%
lead for AMD on 1440p AMD pulls ahead a
bit offering more FPS in the majority of
titles and ending up about 5% faster on
average in these 30 games and on 4K
resolution it looks about the same as on
1440p Nvidia wins some AMD wins some
more and again AMD is ahead by 6ish %
which is very nice considering it is a
cheaper product of the two but it is
very very important to understand here
that all these uh gaming percentages can
be completely different depending on uh
if you test more games that prefer
Nvidia or you test more games that just
prefer AMD uh it can also depend on
which game settings you're using uh
which part of the game you're in or if
you're just using a built-in Benchmark
and this time around it can even really
really depend on which G CPU model
you're using for your testing now as I
said at the beginning of this video I'm
currently testing the gigabyte 7800 XT
gaming OC for example uh which looks to
be about 5% faster than the reference
model I use for this video so do not
just compare these raw percentage
numbers to other review channels and
then expect them to be exactly the same
but just try to watch as many
comparisons as possible and then use
that information to form a wider picture
I would say if you want to know the
exact system configuration we use for
our testing uh do check the description
of this video because I will leave all
the details down there anyway uh one
area where AMD still has some catching
up to do is power consumption on average
our 7800 XT used about 252 watts
compared to 196 Watts for the RTX 4070
so there is 56 Watts between the two
cards and that might make a significant
difference depending on how much time
you spend gaming and how much you pay
for electricity in your region so if
your electricity is very cheap uh let's
say 10 cents per kilowatt hour and you
only game about 2 hours per day on
average uh you're only looking at a bit
over $15 of a difference over a 4year
long period which no one should really
care about but if you play a bit more
and you pay a bit more you might end up
spending the money you just saved on a
6800 XD on your power bill instead uh
Shifting the value slightly in nvidia's
favor or if you're in the EU with much
more expensive power the difference can
start to be a real problem for AMD so if
you game a lot while paying 35 cents per
kilowatt hour like many of us do here in
the Netherlands uh the 7800 XT might
actually end up costing you more and if
we have another very problematic winter
like we did last year when the rates
actually went up to €1 EUR per kilowatt
hour buying the more efficient GPU could
end up costing you a lot less in the
long run but hopefully that will never
happen again so overall I do think that
this new GPU will make sense for some
people but not so much for others and
there is definitely some things I do
like about this new card but there also
some things that need to be discussed
first of all I really don't agree with
the naming of this card because for some
people that don't spend a lot of time
looking at reviews and looking at
numbers it is not clear enough that the
7800 XT is not really an upgrade if you
already own a 3year old 6800 XD uh you
do get slightly better efficiency than
the last gen cards you get some newer
features like av1 encoding for example
but the overall raw performance is only
a very tiny bit better than you get on a
similarly named 3-year-old card and just
like I said for recent Nvidia launches
uh it really feels like they're doing
the bare minimum for these cards to just
barely make sense instead of making
exciting products that we all want to
see which is kind of disappointing if
you were deciding between these two dpus
because they do cost the same I would
get the 7800 XT unless the price of the
6800 XT drops even further for 1440p
resolution specifically I think that the
7800 XT does a great job at making the
RTX 460 Titi even more pointless than it
was before for uh the radiant does cost
a bit more and it uses a bit more power
but it is also a lot faster now you can
argue that nvidia's feature set is still
a bit stronger the dlss is still ahead
of FSR and Nvidia offers functional
frame generation while amd's FSR is
still in the promise phase but 40 plus%
extra raw performance that the 7800 XT
offers is more than enough to make you
forget about all those feature
differences if you're already with
willing to spend $400 on an 8 GB 460 TI
I really suggest you spend a bit more on
this much faster 16 GB card instead and
then especially so if you do plan on
upgrading to 4K resolution somewhere in
the future the RTX 470 is the main
competitor that potential 7800 XT buyers
should look into before making a
decision the 7800 XT is a bit cheaper it
has a bit more memory and it's a little
bit faster if we look at a r i games but
the performance difference between them
is very very small and it depends on
which game you're looking at so at this
point uh some features or better
efficiency might be a deciding factor
between the two cards and Nvidia does
have a stronger feature set at the
moment and it does use less power so the
RTX 4070 remains a strong option unless
you just want to play Call of Duty or
Starfield uh but you know who knows GPU
prices in general do seem to be going
down and if this AMD card ends up being
even cheaper than the 4070 it would be a
clear recommendation still I'm very
happy that there is a more competition
in this segment uh even though I'm also
a bit disappointed it's not as exciting
as I wanted it to be but either way I
really do hope that this video was
helpful enough to give you an idea of
what to expect in more than 30 different
games and if you want to know how the
gigabyte 7 800 XT performs as well as
their 7700 XT do check my next video
that I will hopefully finish tomorrow
now that's all I had for today but
before I go let's check out the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by sionic and their brand new vertex
power supplies these fully modular power
supplies are extremely efficient and
very quiet due to their fan design and
their hybrid fan mode that stops the
fans completely under 40% load they come
with a variety of connections for any
kind of systems you have in mind
including the new 12volt high power
cable for the latest RTX graphics cards
and as a little bonus you get a cozy
10year long warranty check them out
using the links in the description below
thank you all for watch thank you all
for watching and for sticking to the end
uh if you liked it if you want to see
more videos like this one do consider
clicking that subscribe button bye guys
and I will see you in the next
[Music]
one
morning